police in the netherlands have arrested
two suspects over the shooting of
prominent investigative journalist peter
devries
the men are due in court on friday
authorities are investigating
investigating links to devries's
reporting on a major criminal gang
european leaders say his shooting was
also an attack on freedom of the press
peter dufrese is known for exposing the
dutch underworld
sometimes digging up evidence to help
bring justice to victims
and speaking out for survivors now the
investigative journalist
lies in an amsterdam hospital fighting
for his life
this surveillance footage shows devries
walking down a nearly empty street
moments before he was attacked a gunman
shot him up to
five times including once in the head
people have come to the scene of the
crime to lay flowers
to think of his contributions to dutch
society and to pray for his recovery
if you think of all these subjects in
the past years
and his opinion his his work
that he contributed to society
you cannot think him away so so i just
hope
that uh everything's going to be fine
with him i hope that
he will survive this so because he's a
very important
person in in holland and in in
journalism
defrees had been recently involved in
the trial of the alleged leader
of a criminal organization prosecutors
called an
oiled killing machine the 64 year old
had long been considered a possible
target of the criminals he reported on
two suspects are in custody in
connection with his shooting
they are scheduled to be in court on
friday
a third man was detained but later
released
police have not revealed a possible
motive but journalists
politicians and citizens believe the
attack is aimed at silencing reporters
we also think that journalists
who might be targeted by organized crime
must be protected it's very important
and it is very important
that this murder attempt does not have a
chilling effect
on that journalists working on criminal
affairs
the netherlands rarely sees violent
crimes but some say
their parent targeting of defrees has
shaken their sense of security
dw's max zander is in amsterdam
following this story
for us he joins us now max is there any
update on peter devries's condition what
are you hearing there
right so we know pita defreeze is in
hospital and he's being heavily guarded
by police due to security reasons
also due to security security reasons
most likely there's
not much information coming out of the
hospital what we know from reports is
that he was
struck here in the street where i'm i'm
standing here right now he was
uh apparently shot in the head so he we
have reason to believe he's in a very
critical condition and this is also what
something uh a fellow journalist
colleague
the chief of atta el where pita de frise
was attending
a talk show uh just just in the hour
before he was
shot here said reiterated that peter
defries is in hospital and he indeed is
still
fighting for his life what about the
suspects
what more do we know about them and
their motives
well two men were apprehended by police
were arrested in the hours
after the shooting they were traveling
in a car outside of amsterdam had left
the city
approximately 40 kilometers from the
city when they were pulled over by
police
one of the suspects is a 35 year old
polish citizen the other is a 21 year
old
dutch citizen one of them is believed to
be the shooters
the police have subsequently searched
their apartments they came up with hard
drives they also came up with ammunition
and another interesting piece of
information here is that
the polish citizen apparently was in
police custody
prior to the shooting a week a week
before this it's not yet clear under
what circumstances
as to their motives also a lot is still
in the unknown
peter de frise is the top uh criminal
journalist here in the netherlands he's
been shining a light on the criminal
underworld for the last 40 years
so he has a lot of enemies but still
it's not yet clear whether or not or how
this work influenced
this attempt on his life what's the
reaction
been like there in amsterdam
well a journalist being shot in a
western democracy or in
western europe in a busy city uh that's
something that doesn't happen every day
so naturally
uh the continent the the nation and the
and the city uh
was uh or is still in shock as you can
see behind me
this is the this is the area um this is
the the the spot where pita defreeze
was shot um the day before yesterday and
the people
people came by to pay their respects lay
down flowers to light candles uh they
were pretty
heartwarming and poignant uh personal
messages uh to peter de fries for him to
get better
um so he for many people here he's seen
as a hero who they idolize and
there's a lot of wishes for him to get
better soon all right max thank you dw's
max sander in amsterdam